the following is a conversation with
donald knuth his second time on this
podcast
don is a legendary computer scientist
touring award winner
father of algorithm analysis
author of the art of computer
programming creator of tech that led to
late tech and one of the kindest and
most fascinating human beings i've ever
got a chance to talk to
i wrote him a letter a long time ago he
responded and the rest as they say is
history we've interacted many times
since then and every time it's been
joyful and inspiring
to support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description
this is the lex friedman podcast and
here is my conversation with donald
knuth
your first large-scale program you wrote
it in ibm 650 assembler in the summer of
1957. i wrote it in decimal machine
language i didn't know about assembler
until a year later but the year 1957 the
year and the program
yeah i might have learned about it
assembler later that summary i probably
did in 1957 hardly anybody had heard of
assemblers you looked at the user
manuals
how did you write a program for this
machine it would be it would
it would say um
you know you would say 69 which meant
load the distributor and and then you
would give the address of the number you
wanted to load into the distributor
uh yesterday
uh my friend that
doug spicer at the computer history
museum sent me a link to
something that just went on youtube it
was the ibm's
progress report from 1956 which is you
know very contemporary with 1957 yes
and in 1956 ibm had donated to stanford
university on ibm 650 one of the first
ones
when they showed a picture of the
assembly line for ibm 650s and they said
you know this is number 500 or something
coming off the assembly line and i had
never
seen so many ibm 650s i did in this
movie that was a it's on youtube now
um
and
and it showed the picture from
stanford
uh that that you know they they said
look you know we donated one of these to
stanford one to mit and they mentioned
one other
another college
and in in december of 56 they donated to
to my university case tech
but anyway
they showed a picture then
a class session
where a guy was teaching programming and
on the blackboard it said 69
8 000 i mean he
it was
he was teaching them how to write
uh
code for this ibm 650 which was in
decimal
numbers
so so the instructions were tended ten
decimal digits you had two digits that
said what
what to do for they just say uh
uh what to do it too
and four more digits to say where to get
your next instruction
and there's a manual that describes what
each of the numbers mean and the manual
was actually one
if the manual had been well written i
probably never would have gone into
computer science but it was so badly
written i figured
that i must have a talent for it because
i'm only a freshman and i and i could
write a better manual
uh
and that he did
and so i i started working at the
computer center um
and
and uh
wrote some manuals then but but yeah but
but this was uh
but this was the way we did it and and
my first program then was june of 1957
the tic-tac-toe
no that was the second program the first
the third program the first program was
factoring
a number okay so you dial a number on
the
on the um
uh their switches that means you sat at
this big mainframe
and
and you turn the dials and set a number
and and then it would punch out uh the
factors of that number on on cars so
that's the input is the number the input
was
yeah the input what was the number yeah
attended a number and
and uh and the output was uh its factors
and and and i wrote that program
uh
i still have a copy of it somewhere
and um how many lines of code do you
remember well yeah it started out as
about
20 but then i kept having to debug it
and i i discovered debugging of course
when i wrote my first program and what
does uh debugging look like
on a program with just all numbers
well you sit there and you uh i don't
remember how i got it into the machine
but i but i think there was a way to
punch punch it on cards so each each
instruction would would be one
one card or maybe i could get seven
instructions on the card eight
instructions i don't know but anyway
so i'm sitting there at the console of
the machine i mean i'm doing this at
night when nobody else is around of
course um and
and so you have one set of switches
where you can dial the number i'm
inputting but there's another switch
that's it that you know that says okay
now execute one instruction and show me
what you thought what you did
or or you or you
there was another four switches and say
stop if you get to those if if you get
to that instruction
so so i can say now go until you get
there again and watch okay so i could
watch
you know it he would take that number
and it would divide it by two and if
it's
you know there's no remainder then okay
two is a factor so
so then i work on the but if if not
divisible by two divide by three okay
keep trying and you know
until you know you're you're at the end
and uh you would find a bug
if uh if you were just surprised that
something weird happened
well certainly i mean
first of all i might have it
you know try to divide by one instead of
two you off by one errors that people
make all the time you know but but maybe
i go to the wrong instruction maybe i
you might maybe i uh
i left left something in a register that
i shouldn't have done but the first bugs
were pretty you know i i i probably
on the first night i was able to i was
able to get the factors of 30 you know
as equal to two three and five okay
um so you're sorry to interrupt you were
so you're sitting there late at night
yeah so
it feels like you spent many years late
at night working on a computer oh yeah
so like what what's that like so most
the world is sleeping
and you have to be there at night
because that's when you get access to
the computer between my freshman
sophomore year i didn't need sleep you
know
i used to do all-nighters when i was in
high school i used to
i used to
do the
uh the whole student newspaper every
monday night i would i would you know i
would just stay up all night and
and it would be done on tuesday morning
um
that was because i i didn't get ulcers
and stuff like that until later you know
but but but uh well the uh i don't know
if you know rodney brooks rod brooks of
course yeah he he he told he told me a
story that
he really you're you know he really
looked up to you he was actually afraid
of you
vice versa i must say
but when he tells a story when you were
working on tech
that they screwed up something with a
machine
i think this might have been mit i don't
know
and you were waiting for them to fix the
machine so you can get back to work late
at night oh oh
that happened all the time
he was really intimidated he's like dr
newt is not happy with this
that's interesting but no no the the
machine at stanford ai lab was
uh uh i
was down
an awful lot because we they had
they had many talented programmers
changing the operating system every day
and so operating system was getting
better every day but
it was also crashing so so so i i wrote
almost the entire manual for tech during
down time
[Music]
that much but that's another story okay
well he was saying they uh it's a
hardware problem they they uh they tried
to fix it and they reinserted something
and smoke was everywhere because he was
hurt well that didn't happen as often as
the operation coming from but yeah
and it was it's a funny story because
you're saying there's this
tall
uh don knuth that i look up to and
there was pressure to i think it's the
computer well
it's funny
okay the kind of things we remember that
stick in our memory well okay yeah well
i i i could tell you a bunch of rod
brooks stories too but let's
let's let let's go back to the 650. so
so um
so i'm debugging this my first program
and and i i
i had more bugs in it than a number of
lines of code i i mean the number of
lines of code kept growing
and let me explain so so i had to punch
the answers on cards all right
so so suppose i suppose i'm factoring
the number 30 then i got then it i got a
i got to put two
somewhere on the card i got to put a
three somewhere on the card i got to put
a five somewhere on the card right and
and you know what my i was my first
program i i probably screwed up and you
know it
it fell off the edge of the card or
something like that but but i didn't
realize that there are some tentative
numbers that have
that have more than eight um factors
and the card has only 80 columns and so
i need 10 columns for every factor
so my first program didn't take account
for the fact that i would have to punch
more than one card
my first program you know just line the
stuff up in memory and then it punched
the card but but after you know so by
the time i finished i had to i had to
deal with lots of lots of things also i
uh uh
if you if you put a large prime number
in there my program might have sat there
for for 10 minutes the 650 was pretty
slow and so it would sit there spinning
its wheels and you wouldn't know if it
was in a loop or whatever you said ten
digit
ten digits yeah so i think the largest
is sort of nine nine nine nine nine nine
nine nine nine seven or something like
that and
that would you know that that would take
me a while
uh
for that first one anyway that was my
first program well what was your goal
with that program well there's something
you were
hoping to
find a large prime maybe or no
the opposite you know my goal was to see
the lights flashing and
understand how how this magical machine
would be able to do something that took
so long by hand so what was your second
program my second program was
uh was
a converted number
from
from binary to decimal or something like
that it was much much simpler it didn't
have that many bugs in it
my third program was tic-tac-toe yeah
and he had some machi so the the the
tic-tac-toe program
is interesting on many levels but one of
them is that it has some
you can call machine learning in it
that's
yeah that's right uh
uh
i don't know how long it's going to be
before
the name of
our field has changed from computer
science to machine learning
but
but anyway uh uh it it was my first
experience with machine learning because
okay so here we had yeah how does the
program well first of all
what is the problem you were solving
what is tic tac toe what are we talking
about and then um right
how was it designed
right so so
you got a three by three grid and each
each each
each could be in three states it can be
empty or it can have an x or an o yeah
right so three to the ninth is a
uh well what is
how big is it i should know
um but it's 80
81 times 81 times three so
um
anyway
eight is like two to the third and so
that would be
uh that would be like two to the sixth
um
uh and then uh but that would be 64 then
you have to anyway i love how you're
doing the calculation
anyway the three comes from the fact
that it's either empty an x or an o
right
and
the 650 what was it was a machine that
had only uh
two thousand
ten digit words
you go from zero zero zero zero to one
nine nine nine and that's it
and and in each word you have a ten
digit number
so that's not many bits i mean i gotta
have three in order to have a memory of
every position i've seen
i need three to the ninth bits
okay but it was a decimal machine too it
didn't have bits but but but it did have
it it did have
strange instruction
where if if you had a tentative number
that but all the digits were either
eight or nine
uh
you you'd be eight nine nine eight or
something like that that would
uh you you could make a test whether it
was eight or nine that was one of the
strange things ibm engineers put into to
the machine i have no idea what well um
hardly ever used but anyway i i needed
one digit for every
every position i'd seen
uh zero meant it was a bad position i
meant it was good position
i i think i started out at five or six
you know but if you if you win a game
then you uh
then you increase the value of that
position for you but you decrease it
for your opponent uh uh so but but i i i
could
i had that much total memory for every
every possible position was one digit
and i had a total of 20 000 digits
which had which had to also include my
program
yes and all the logic and everything
including how to
how to ask
the user what the moves are and things
like this okay so so i think i had to
work it out because get every every
position in tic-tac-toe
it is equivalent to
roughly eight others because you you you
can rotate the board
um
which gives you factor four and you can
also flip it over
and that's another factor two so so i
might you know so i might have needed
only three to the ninth over eight
positions about you know plus
plus a little bit
uh so i had but anyway that was
that was a a part of the program to to
squeeze it into this tiny
so you tried to find an efficient
representation that took account for
that kind of rotation i had to otherwise
i couldn't do the learning
uh wow so so but but i had three
parts to my tic-tac-toe program
uh and i called it brain one brain two
and brain three so brain one
just played
a um
let's see
at random
okay
it's your turn okay you gotta put an x
somewhere he has to go in an empty space
but that's that's it okay
choose
to choose one and and play it uh
brain two
uh
had a canned routine
and i think it was it also
maybe it had
maybe it assumed you were the first
player or maybe it allowed you to be
first i think you were odd to be either
first of a second but had a canned
built-in strategy known to be optimum
for tic-tac-toe
[Music]
before i forget by the way
i learned uh many years later that
charles babbage
had had planned to
had thought about programming
tic-tac-toe for his
for his dream machine that he that he
was never able to finish wow so that was
the program he thought about more than a
hundred years ago yeah yeah he had he
he did that okay
and i had but and and i had however been
influenced by a
demonstration at the at the museum of
science and industry in chicago it's
like it's like boston's science museum i
think bell labs had had prepared a
special exhibit about
telephones and relay technology and they
had a tic-tac-toe playing
uh
machine as part of that exhibit so that
had been one of my
uh you know something i'd seen
before i was a freshman in college and
and inspired me to see if i could write
a program for
okay so so anyway i had brain one
random
you know uh
knowing nothing brain two knowing
everything
then brain three was the learning one
and and i could
i i could play
brain one against brain one brain one
against brain two and so on and so uh
you could also play against the user
against the live members but
but uh so so i started going the the
learning thing and i said okay you know
take two random
random people uh just playing uh uh
tic-tac-toe uh uh knowing nothing
um and
after about i i forget the number now
but but it converged after about 600
games
uh uh to a safe draw
the way
my program learned was actually it
learned how not to make mistakes because
you know how to
it didn't try to do anything
for winning it just tried to yeah drop
losing and not lose so that was probably
because of the way i did i designed the
learning thing i could have you know
had a different
uh reinforcement function that that
would
that would reward brilliant play but
anyway it didn't
and uh and and if if i took a novice
against the uh
you know the skilled player uh it it was
able to learn uh how to play a good game
so that was that and that was really
mike
but after i finished that i i felt i i
understood programming
was there um
did you
did a curiosity and interest in learning
systems persist for you
so
why why did you want brain three to
learn
yeah i i think naturally it's
we're talking about rod brooks like
he he was teaching all kinds of
very small devices
to to learn stuff
um if a leaf drops off of a tree uh uh
you know it
he was saying something well it learns
if there's wind or not
but but i i mean he pushed that a little
bit too far but
he said he could probably train some
little mini bugs to to scour out dishes
if he had enough
financial support i don't know
can i can i ask you about that because
he he also mentioned that during
those years
there was discussion about
inspired by touring about computation
you know of what is computation
yeah
and
yeah i never thought about any stuff
like that that was
that that was way
too philosophical i mean
i i was a
i was a freshman
after all i mean
i i didn't
i was pretty much a machine
so it's almost like yeah i got you it's
a tinkering mindset
uh not a philosophical mindset
it was just exciting to me to
be able to control something but not
but not
but not to say hmm am i solving a big
problem or something like that or is is
this a step for humankind right no no
way
when did you first start thinking about
computation in the big sense
you know like the universal turing
machine well
i mean i had to pass an ex i
had to take i had to take uh
classes on
computability when i was a senior
so you know we read this book by martin
davis and
yeah this is cool stuff but you know i i
learned about it because i you know i
needed to pass the exams but i didn't
i didn't invent any of that before stuff
but but i i had great fun playing with
the machine you know i um i wrote
program because it was fun to write
programs and and
and get
this
i i mean it was like watching miracles
happen
you mentioned in in an interview that
when reading a program you can tell when
the author of the program changed
oh okay uh
how the heck can you do that like what
makes a distinct style for a programmer
do you think
you know there's different hemingway
has a style of writing
versus james joyce or something
well those are pretty yeah those are
pretty easy to imitate but
it's the same with music and whatever
you can
i i i i found uh
well during the pandemic i
spent a lot more time playing the piano
and i i found something that i'd had
i i had it right when i was taking
lessons uh
you know
before i was a teenager and uh
it was
yankee doodle
uh played in the style of
you know and
i you had you had beethoven and you had
wc and chopin and you know and the last
one was gershwin
and
and
i played over and over again i thought
it was so brilliant because but
but it was so easy but also to
appreciate how
this uh this
author mario somebody or other had
had been able to uh reverse engineer
the styles of of those components so but
now specifically uh to your question i
mean there would be
there it was
it was pretty obvious in this program i
was reading it was it was a compiler
uh and it had been written by a team
at at carnegie mellon
and uh i have no idea
which program
was responsible for but but it you would
get to a part where the guy would just
not know how he how to move things
between registers very efficiently and
so
and so everything that
that could be done in one instruction
would take three or something like that
that would be a pretty obvious uh
change in style but there were but then
there were also you know flashes of
brilliance where you could do in one
instruction normally i used two because
because you knew enough about the way
the machine worked that you could
that that you could accomplish two goals
in one step
so it was mostly the the brilliance of
the concept more than the
uh semicolons and uh or the
the you know the use of short sentences
versus long sentences something like
that so you would see the idea in the
code and you can see the the different
style of thinking experience right it
was yeah so it was stylistic
i mean like i could identify authors by
their
by the amount of technical aptitude they
had but not by
styling the sense of
rhythm or something like that so if you
think about mozart beethoven bach if
somebody looked at don knuth code would
they be able to tell
that this
is a distinct style of thinking going on
here what do you think
and what what would be the defining uh
characteristic of the style
well
my code now is it
is literate programming so i'm it's a
combination of english and c mostly but
but but if you just looked at the c part
of it you would also probably notice
that i don't
got it
you know that i use a lot of global
variables that other people don't and
and and i expand things inline more than
instead of calling
anyway i have different
subset of c that i use okay but this
that's a little bit stylistic yeah
but but with literate programming you
alternate between english and
and c or whatever
and
um and by the way people listening to
this should look up literate programming
it's very interesting uh concept that
you
uh you proposed and developed over the
years
yeah yeah
i'm
that's the most
significant thing
i think to come out of the tech project
is
it is that i uh
i i realized that
uh
my programs
were to be read by people and not not
just by computers and
and that typography could
massively enhance that and
and and so uh
i mean it
they're just wonderful if they're gonna
look it up that they should also look up
this book by
called physically based rendering
by matt farr and
anyway it
got an academy award
but it's but but but all the if
on the graphic effects you see in movies
uh
like
you know are accomplished by algorithms
and this book it is the whole book is a
literate program it tells you not only
how you do all the shading and
and uh
bringing images in that you need for
animation and textures and so on but it
also uh you can run the code
uh
so uh and
and so uh
i find it uh an extension of the way i
uh of of how to teach programming is it
is but by
by telling a story
as part of the program so it's uh it
works as a program but it's also
readable by humans
yes and especially by me
yeah a week later or a year later that's
a good test if you yourself understand
the code yeah
easily a week or more or a year later
yeah
so it it it's uh
what's this piece it's the greatest
thing since sliced bread
programming
or literate literate program okay
uh
you heard it here first okay you uh
dodged this question in an interview i
listened to
uh so let me ask you again here
uh what makes for a beautiful program
what makes for a beautiful program yeah
what are the characteristics you see
like you just said literate programming
what are the characteristics you see in
a program that make you sit back and say
that's pretty good
well the reason i didn't answer is
because there are there are dozens and
dozens of answers to that because
because
each you can define beauty
the same personal defined beauty a
different way from hour to hour i mean
it depends on what
and what you're looking for
at one level you it's it's beautiful
just if it works at all
another level it's beautiful if it's
if it uh
uh
uh
it can be understood easily
it's beautiful if it
if it's illiterate programming it's
beautiful it makes you laugh i mean
yeah i'm actually so i'm with you i
think beauty
if it's readable
readable yeah if you understand what's
going on and also understand
the elegance of thought behind it
and then
also as you said wit and humor i was
always uh i remember having this
conversation i had this conversation on
stack overflow
whether humor is good in comments
and i think it is whether huma is good
in comments like uh when you add
comments in code yeah
i always thought a little bit of humor
is good
it shows personality
it shows character shows wit and fun and
all those kinds of things
of the personality of the programmers
yeah okay so
uh a couple days ago i received
a wonderful present from my former
editor at aston wesley he
he's downsizing his house and he found
uh
that
somebody at the company had
had found all that all of their internal
files about the art of computer
programming from the 1960s and they gave
it to him
uh and then
you know before throwing string in the
garbage
and then so he said oh yeah he
he planned to keep it for posterity but
now he realized that posterity is a
bit too much for him to handle so he
sent it to me
and so
and so i just received uh
this big big stack of
of letters uh
some of which i had written to them but
but many of which they had written to
early guinea pigs who were
telling them whether they should publish
or not you know
and one of the things
was uh
uh
in in the uh in the comments to volume
one uh
uh
the the major the major reader was was
bob floyd
uh
who is my great
uh co-worker in the 60s um died early
unfortunately but but uh
and and he
he commented about the humor
so we had you know he ran it by me you
know says
you know keep this joke in or not you
know um
they also sent it out to focus groups
what do you think about humor in
a book about computer programming what's
the conclusion and i stated my
philosophy is it said you know the ideal
thing
is uh
that it's it's it's something where
the reader knows that there's probably a
joke here if you only understood it and
this is a motivation
to understand
to think about it a little bit um but
anyway it it it's a very delicate humor
i mean it's it's it's really uh
each each century invents a different
kind of humor too i mean
and
different cultures have different
different kinds of humor um yeah like uh
we met we talked about russia a little
bit offline uh you know there's dark
humor
and
you know what
when a country goes to something
different right any of that life and
stuff like this
yo and jack benny i mean
steve allen wrote this book about
humor and it was the most boring book
but he was one of my idols but
but uh
yeah
it's called the funny men or something
like that but yeah okay so anyway i i
think it's important to know that
that this is part of life and and it
should be fun and not yeah and and so
you know i wrote this
this organ composition which uh uh is
based on the bible but i didn't refrain
from putting little jokes in it
also in the music it's hidden in the
music it's it's it's there yeah
a little humor is okay yeah i mean
not egregious humor
so in in this correspondence you know
there were
there were things i said yeah i really
shouldn't have i i really shouldn't have
done that
but uh but other ones i could you know i
insisted on and i've got
jokes in there
that no that
nobody has figured out you in fact
in volume 2
i've got a
cryptogram a message
in cypher
and in order to decipher it you're going
to have to
have to break an rsa key which is
larger than people know how to break
uh and so
you know if computers keep getting
faster and faster then you know might be
100 years but somebody will figure out
what this message is and they will laugh
i mean i've got a joke in there
so that one you really have to work for
uh i i don't know if you've heard about
this
let me explain it maybe you'll find it
interesting
so open ai is a company that
does uh ai work and they have this
language model it's a neural network
that can generate
language pretty well
but they also
of on top of that develop something
called
openai codex
and together with github they developed
a system called openai copilot
let me explain what it does
there's echoes of literate programming
in it
so what you do is you start writing code
and it completes the code for you
so for example you start let's go to
your factoring program you start you
write in javascript and python in any
language
that it trained on uh you start
you write the first line and some
comments like what this code does and it
generates the function for you
and it does an incredibly good job like
it's not provably right but it often
does a really good job of completing the
code for you i see whether
but how do you know whether it did a
good job or not
you could see a lot of examples where he
did a good job
and so you it it's not a thing that
generates the code for you it starts
it gives you uh
so it puts the human in the seat of
fixing
issues versus writing from scratch do
you find that kind of idea at all
interesting
every year we're going to be losing more
and more
control over what machines are doing and
people are saying well it seemed to like
when i was a professor at caltech
uh in this in the 60s we had this
this guy who
who talked a good game
he could give inspiring lectures and
you'd think well
certainly things he was talking about an
hour later you said well what did he say
um
but what but
but he really felt that it didn't matter
whether computers got the right answer
or not it just mattered whether it made
you happy or not in other words if you
you know if
if if your boss paid for it uh he
you know then you had a job you could
you know you could
you could take care of your wife
happiness is more important than truth
exactly he didn't believe in truth but
he was a philosopher
i like
it and somehow you you see uh
we're going that way i mean
so many more things are are taken over
by saying well this seems to work
and so and when there's
when there is uh competing interests
involved neither side understands
why the decision is being made
you know we realize now that it's that
is bad but but consider what happens
five private ten year year down the line
when things get even more
further detached and each thing is based
on
something
from the previous year yeah so you start
to lose the more you automate the more
you start to lose track of uh some deep
experimentally
exponentially but so that's the dark
side the positive side is
the more you automate the more you let
humans do what humans do best
so
maybe programming
this you know maybe
humans should focus on a small part of
programming that requires that genius
the magic of the human mind
and the mess you let the machine
generate yeah i mean they're that's the
that's the positive but of course it
does come with the darkness like
automation
what what's better correct i'm never
going to try to write a book about that
uh i'm never going to recommend to any
of my students to work for them
so you you're on the side of i'm on the
side i'm on the side of honor happiness
understanding i understand
and i i think these things are really
marvelous if they if
if what they do is you know
all of a sudden we have a better medical
diagnosis or or or you know it will help
guide some scientific experiment or
something like this uh
you know you know curing diseases or
what whatever but
but when it
when it affects people's lives in a
serious way uh uh
so if you're writing if you're writing
code for geeky oh yeah here this is
great
this will make a slaughter bot okay
so i see so
you have to be very careful
like right now it seems like fun and
games it's useful to write a little
javascript program that helps you with
the website
but like you said one year passes two
years passes five years and you forget
you start building on top of it and then
all of a sudden you have autonomous
weapon systems
based
well we're all dead it doesn't matter in
that sense
well in the end
the this whole thing ends anyway so
um but it it
there is a heat death of the universe
predicted but i i'm trying to postpone
that for
for a little bit
well it'd be nice that at the end
as we approach the heat death of the
universe there's
still some kind of consciousness there
to
to to to appreciate it
hopefully human consciousness i'll
settle for 10 to the 10 to the 10 to the
10th year some finite number but
but
things like this might be the reason we
don't pick up any
signals from
extraterrestrial
they don't want anything to do with us
oh because they because they
they invented it too and
so you you do have a little bit of worry
on the
existential threats of
ai and automation
so like like removing the human from the
picture et cetera yeah people have more
more potential to
to do harm now than
by far than they did a 100 years ago
but are you optimistic about so the
humans are good at creating destructive
things but also humans are good at
solving problems yeah i mean there's
half empty and have full you know that
so
how yeah we have full or what i can go
yeah so so let me let me put it this way
because
because it's the only way i can be
optimistic but but
but
think of um
of
things that have changed because of
civilization
you know they don't occur just in nature
so just
uh just imagine that the room we're in
for example
okay some
you know we've got
pencils we've got books we've got tables
we've got microphones
clothing food
all these things were added
somebody invented them one by one and
millions of things
uh that we inherit okay
and
it's inconceivable that that so many
millions of billions of things uh
wouldn't have problems and
we we get it all right
um and and each one
would have no
negative
effects and so on so it it's very
amazing that it much works as does work
it's
it's incredibly amazing
and actually that's the source of my
optimism as well
including for artificial intelligence
so
we we drive over bridges
we we use all kinds of technology we
don't know how it works and there's
millions of brilliant people involved in
building a small part of that and it
doesn't go wrong and it works and i mean
that
it it works
and it doesn't go go wrong
often enough to suffer and we can
identify things that aren't working and
and try to
improve on them
in a sub often suboptimal way oh
absolutely but it's
but but the
the kind of things that
i know how to
improve
require human beings to be rational and
i i'm losing my confidence that human
beings are rational
yeah
yeah now here you go again with the
worst case uh worst case analysis
they may not be rational but they're um
they're they're
clever and uh
beautiful in their own kind of way yeah
i tend to think that most people
um have the desire and the capacity to
be good to each other
and love will ultimately win out like if
they're given the opportunity that's
where they lean
in the art of computer programming you
wrote the real problem is that
programmers have spent far too much time
worrying about efficiency in the wrong
places and at the wrong times
premature optimization is the root of
all evil
in parentheses or at least most of it in
programming
can you uh explain this idea
uh what's the wrong time what is the
wrong place for our optimization so
first of all the word optimization i i
started out writing software uh and
optimization was i was a compiler writer
so optimization meant uh making the
uh
making a better translation it it so
that it would run faster on it on a
machine instead of an optimized program
it's just like you know you you you run
a program and you set the optimization
level uh for
the compiler so that's one
word for optimization
um and at that time i
i happened to be looking in an
unabridged dictionary
uh for some reason or other and i came
to work optimizing
what's the meaning of the word optimized
and it says to view with optimism
and you look in webster's dictionary of
english language in 1960 early 1960s
that's what optimized me meant okay
so people
started doing cost optimization other
kinds of things uh
you know whole subfields of
of
algorithms and economics and whatever
are are based on what they call
optimization now but
but
to me optimization when i was saying
that
was saying uh uh changing a program to
make it more
tuned to the machine
and i found out that uh
when a person writes a program
uh
he
he or she
tends to think that
the parts that were hardest to write are
going to be hardest for the computer to
execute
so
maybe i have 10 pages of code but
i i had to work a week writing this page
i i mentally think that when the
computer gets to that page it's going to
slow down
right uh it's chris oh i don't
understand what i'm doing i better
be more anyway this is of course
silly but it's it's something that we
that we
that we don't know when we write a piece
of code we don't know what
what whether the computer is actually
going to be executing that code very
much
so so people had had a very
poor understanding of
of
what the computer was actually doing
i i made one test where
where we studied a fortran compiler
and it was spending more than 80 of its
time reading the comments card
[Music]
but as a programmer we were really
concerned about how fast it could take a
complicated expression that had lots of
levels of parenthesis and
and and and convert that in
into something but that was just you
know less than one percent of the uh
so if we optimized that
uh
we didn't know what we were doing but
but but if if we knew that it was
spending eighty percent of his time on
the comments
card you know in ten minutes we could we
could make the the compiler run more
than twice as fast and you can only do
that once you've completed the program
and then you empirically study where i
had some kind of profiling that i knew
what was important yeah so
you don't think the supplies generally i
mean there's something that rings true
to this across the board i'm glad that
it applied generally but but it was it
was only my good luck
i said it but you know but but i did but
i said it in limited context and not and
and i'm glad if it
makes people think about stuff because i
i
but
it applies
in another sense too that is
sometimes i will
do optimization in a way that does help
the
the actual running time
but makes the program impossible to
change next week
because i've changed my data structure
of something that
that made it less adaptable so one of
the great uh
principles of computer science is
is
it is laziness or whatever you call it
the
late binding uh you know don't
hold off decisions when you can
um
and
and and you know and we understand now
quantitatively how valuable that is
what do you mean we understand so you
mean people
people have written thesis about how you
can how late binding will
it will improve the i mean you know just
in time manufacturing or whatever
you can make you can defer a decision
instead of doing your advanced planning
and say i'm gonna allocate thirty
percent to this and fifty percent so in
all kinds of domains there's an
optimality to laziness in many cases
decision is not made in advance so
instead you you design
in order to be flexible uh uh to to
change with the uh uh
with the way the wind is blowing yeah
but so the reason that line resonated
with a lot of people
is because
uh there's something about the
programmer's mind
that wants that enjoys optimization so
it's a constant struggle
to
balance
laziness
and lay binding with
the desire to optimize
the elegance of a well-optimized code is
something that's compelling to
programming
yeah
it's a
another concept of beauty
let me ask you a weird question
so roger penrose
has talked about computation computers
and
he proposed that
the way the human mind discovers
mathematical ideas is something more
than a computer
that that a universal turing machine
cannot
do everything that a human mind can do
now this includes
discovering mathematical ideas and it
also includes
he's written a book about it
consciousness
so i don't know if you know roger but
yeah
my uh my daughter's kids played with his
kids in oxford
nice
so do you think there is such a limit to
the computer do you think consciousness
is more than a computation do you think
the human mind the way it thinks is more
than a computation
i i mean like i i can say yes or no but
but but i don't i have no reason
i mean
so you don't find it useful to have an
intuition in one way or the other like
when you think about algorithms do you
isn't it
unanswerable question in my opinion is
is no better than anybody else you think
it's unanswerable so you don't think
eventually science
angels can dance on the head i mean i
don't know
but angels
anyway there are lots of things that are
beyond that that we can speculate about
but
i don't want somebody to say oh yeah
canoe said this and and so he's he's
he's smart and so he so that must be
i mean i say it's something that uh
we'll never know
interesting
okay that's a strong statement i i don't
i personally think it's something we
will know eventually like there's no
reason to me why the the workings of the
human mind
are not within the reach of science
that's absolutely possible and i'm not
denying it yeah
uh but right now you don't have a good
intuition i mean that's also possible
you know that and ai
you know created the universe you know
intelligent design
has all been done by an ai yes
this is i mean all these things are but
but but but you're asking me to
to pronounce on it and and i don't have
any expertise i i i i'm a teacher that
passes on knowledge but i don't
but i don't know
the fact that i
that i vote yes or no on
well you do have expertise as a human
not as a not as a teacher
or a scholar of computer science
i mean that's ultimately the realm of
where the discussion of human thought
yeah well i know we're in consciousness
he might even thought he proved it but
no he doesn't he doesn't prove it he is
following intuition but
but i mean you have to ask john mccarthy
john mccarthy
i think
uh we're totally unimpressed by these
statements
so you don't think so even like the
touring paper on
uh on the touring test
that
you know starts by asking can machines
think oh um you don't think these kind
of um
touring doesn't like that question yeah
i don't consider it important let's put
it that way
because it it's in the category of
things that
it it it would be nice you know but i
think it's beyond knowledge and so i
don't
i'm not i'm more interested in knowing
about
the riemann hypothesis or something
so when you say it's an interesting
statement beyond knowledge
yeah i think what you mean
is it's not sufficiently well
it's not even known well enough to be
able to formalize it
in order to ask a clear question yeah
and so that's why it's beyond knowledge
but that doesn't mean it's not
eventually going to be formalized yeah
yeah maybe consciousness will be
understood some some day but uh the last
time i checked
uh
it it was still 200 years away
i haven't been specializing in this by
any means but but but i went to lectures
about it 20 years ago when i was
uh there was there was a symposium at
the american academy in in cambridge and
it started out by saying essentially
everything that's been written about
consciousness is
is hogwash
i tend to
i tend to disagree with that a little
bit so well it's
so consciousness for the longest time
still
is in the realm of philosophy so it's
just conversations without any basis and
yeah understanding
still
i think
once you start creating artificial
intelligence systems that interact with
humans
and they have personality
they have identity you start flirting
with the question of consciousness not
from a philosophical perspective but
from an engineering perspective
and then starts becoming much more
like i feel like yeah yeah don't
misunderstand me i
i i i i certainly don't disagree with
that at all um
and
even at these lectures that we had
you know 20 years ago there were
neurologists
pointing out that
that human beings had actually decided
to do something before they were
conscious of making that decision yeah
uh
i mean they could tell that
you know that signals were being sent to
their arms before they before their they
knew that they were
anything like this
are true and and uh
my uh you know less valiant has
an architecture for the brain and more
recently uh
uh
christus papadomitrio uh
in the academy
science proceedings a year ago uh with
with two other people but i know chris
does very well
uh and and he's got this uh
uh this model of uh
this architecture
by which you could uh create a
uh things that
that correlate well with the uh with
experiments that are done on
consciousness uh
and and and and he
he actually you know has a
a machine language that in which you can
you can write
code and
and test hypotheses
uh
and so it it might you know we might
have a big breakthrough my personal
feeling is that
consciousness
the the best model
i
i've heard of uh to explain the the
miracle of consciousness uh is
that that
that somehow
inside of our
brains
we're having a
a
continual survival for the fittest
competition
as i'm speaking to you
uh all the possible things i might be
wanting to say
are all in there
and there's like a voting going on yeah
right and
one of them is is winning
and and that's affecting the you know
the next sentence and so on yeah uh and
uh
there was this book
machine intelligence or unintelligent on
intelligence yeah bill
atkinson uh was what was it what was a
total
devotee of that book well i like
whether it's consciousness or something
else i like the storytelling part that
we it feels like uh for us
humans it feels like there's a concrete
it's almost like literary programming i
don't know what the programming going on
on the inside but i'm getting a nice
story here about
what happened and it feels like i'm in
control and i'm getting a nice clear
story so but it's also possible there's
a computation going on
that's really messy there's a bunch of
different competing ideas
and in the end it just kind of generates
a story for you to uh
a consistent story for you to believe
and that makes it all nice yeah and so
i prefer to talk about things that i
have some expertise and then things for
which i which i'm only a
uh you know
on the sideline
so there's a tricky thing i don't know
if you have any expertise in this you
might be a little bit on the sideline
it'd be interesting to ask though
what are your thoughts on cellular
automata and the game of life
have you ever played with those kind of
little uh games i think uh the game of
life uh it is
it is wonderful and uh
uh
and
and shows all kind of stuff about how
things
can evolve without the creator
understanding
anything more than
the power of
learning things in a way but to me the
most
important thing about the game of life
is that is is how it
focused for me
what what it meant to have free will or
not
because the game of life is obviously
totally deterministic yes and i i i find
it hard to believe that anybody who's
ever had children
cannot believe in free will
right on the other hand
this makes it crystal clear
john conway said
he wondered whether it was
immoral to shut the computer off after
he got into a particularly interesting
play of the game of life um wow yeah so
there is
to me the reason i love the game of life
is exactly as you said a clear
illustration that from
simple initial conditions with simple
rules you know exactly
how the system is operating is
deterministic
and yet if you let yourself
if if you allow yourself to
lose that knowledge a little bit
enough to see the bigger organisms
that emerge and then all of a sudden
they seem conscious they seem
not conscious but living if if the
universe is finite
we're all living in the game of life to
slow down i mean
it's sped up a lot
but do you think technically
some of the ideas that you used for
analysis of algorithms can be used to
analyze the game of life
can we make sense of it or is it too
weird yeah i mean i i
i've got i've got a dozen exercises in
volume
for
fascicle six uh
that
actually worked rather well for that
purpose
but
bill gospers
came up with the
with the algorithm that that allows
that allowed golly to
uh to
you know to run thousands and thousands
of times faster to
you know the website called golly
g-o-l-l-y it simulates the cellular
automata like game of life yeah you got
you got to check it out yeah
can i ask about john conway
yes in fact i i i'm just reading now the
the issue of mathematical intelligence
or that came in last last week it's a
whole issue devoted to to
uh
you know
remembrance of of him did you know him
i
i slept overnight in his house several
times i
yeah he recently passed away
yeah he got he died a year ago
may
i think it was i've covered
what are you what are some memories of
him of his work that stand out for you
is
did uh
on a technical level did any of his work
inspire you on a personal level that
did he himself inspire you in some way
you know absolutely to all of those
things but
let's see when did i first meet him i
guess i first met him at oxford in like
1967 when i was wow
okay that's a long time ago yeah yeah
you were minus
20 years old or something i don't know
1967.
but but uh
there was a conference where
uh
and i think i spoke
i was speaking about
something that
known as the canoes bendix algorithm now
but but he
he gave it famous talk about knots
and and at the end i didn't know at the
time but but
anyway that talk had now
the source of thousands and thousands of
papers
since then
uh and
it was he was reported on something that
he had done
in high school uh
you know almost ten years earlier
[Music]
before this conference but he never
published it and and he climaxed his
stock by
building some nozzle
you have these lit these little plastic
things that you that you could stick
together
uh it's it's it's
it's something like lego but easier
and so he made a whole bunch of knots in
front of the audience and so on and then
disassembled it
so it was
a dramatic lecture
before he had learned how to give even
more dramatic lectures later
so
all right and
were you at that lecture and i was there
yeah because i had to i was at the same
conference
um
for some reason i was i i happened to be
in in calgary
uh
at the same day that he was visiting
calgary
and it was a spring of of 72
i'm pretty sure
and
and we had lunch together
and
he wrote down during the lunch on a
napkin
uh all of the
facts about
what he called numbers
um and i
and
and he covered the napkin with with the
theorems
about his
his idea of numbers
and i thought which was incredibly
beautiful
um
and
and later in 1972
my sabbatical year began and i went to
norway
and
and in december of that year
uh in the middle of the night
the thought came to me
you know conway's theory about numbers
would be a great
thing to teach students how to invent
research and what the joys are of
research
and
and i and so i said
and i had also
read a book in dialogue
by by alfred rennie
uh
where he was kind of a socratic thing
where the two characters were talking to
each other about mathematics and so i
and so
at the end
in the morning i i
woke up my wife and said
jill
i think i want to write a book about
conway's theory
and
um
you know
you know i'm supposed to be writing the
art of computer programming doing all
this other stuff but i got
but
i really want to write this other book
and
so we made this plan
but i said i thought i could write it in
a week
and
we made the plan then so in january
i i rented a room in a hotel in downtown
austin we were in sabbatical in norway
uh
and i ran at the hotel in in downtown
oslo and um
did nothing else
except write
up conway's theory and and i i changed
the name to surreal numbers that so this
book is now published as surreal number
and um and
you know we figured out we'd always
wonder what what what would he like to
have an affair in a hotel room so so we
figured out that she would visit me
twice during the week
things like this you know we would
you know
try to sneak in this was hotel was was
run by a mission organization these
ladies were
probably very strict but anyway so yeah
so uh and the wild week
in every way but the thing is i had lost
that i had lost that napkin in which you
wrote the theory but but i i
i looked for it but i couldn't find it
so i
tried to recreate from memory what he
told me at that luncheon uh in calgary
and and as i as i wrote the book i i was
going through exactly what i what the
characters in the book were supposed to
be doing so i start with the
with the two axioms that start out the
whole thing and everything is defined it
flows from that but you have to discover
why
and and as a every mistake that i make
as i'm trying to discover it i uh my
characters make two right you know and
and and so it was it's a long long story
and i but but i worked through this week
uh
uh and and it and it was
it it was one of the most exciting
intense weeks of my life and and
and i
i described it in other places but but
but anyway uh
after six days i i finished it and on
the seventh day i rested and
and i sent the right to my secretary to
type it
it was flowing as i was writing it uh
faster than i could think almost
but but but after i finished it uh
and tried to write a letter to my
secretary
telling her how to type it i couldn't
write it anymore
he gave it the muse had left me
completely
can you explain how that week could have
happened like why is that seems like
such a magical week i have no idea but
anyway there was some
it it was almost as if i was channeling
so so
the book
was typed they sent it to conway
and and he said well don you got the
axiom the one axiom wrong
there is a difference between
um
less than or equal and not greater than
i don't know
the opposite of being greater than yeah
and less than or equal but anyway
technically it can make a difference
when you're developing a
logical theory and the way i had chosen
was harder
to do than john's original
so um and we visited him at his house in
cambridge
in april we took a boat actually from
norway
over to across the channel and and so on
and stayed with him for some days and
and uh oh he told he talked
we talked about all kinds of
uh of of things he has
he had
puzzles that i'd never heard of before
he had a great way to
to solve the game of solitaire
many of the
common interests that we you know he'd
never written up and
but but anyway
uh then in the summer time i took
another week off and went to a
a place in in in
the mountains of norway and and rewrote
the book
using the correct axiom
and so so that was the most intensive
connection with
with conway uh after that uh it started
with a napkin it started with an app
connect
but but but we would
run into each other
all that well yeah
the next really impo
i was giving lectures in montreal
uh
i i was giving a series of um
of of seven lectures about the topic
called stable marriages
and
and and he arrived in montreal uh
uh
between my sixth and seventh lecture
and and we met at a party
and uh i i
started telling him about the topic i
was doing and uh he sat and thought
about it he came up with a beautiful
theory
to show that the uh i mean in technical
terms it's it's that the
that the set of all stable marriages it
forms a lattice
and and there was a simple way to find
the greatest lower bound
of of two stable
pairings and
and least upper bound of two stable
married and so i could use it in my
lecture the next day and he came up with
this theorem you know during the party
uh and it it
it's a brilliant yeah it's a
distributive lesson i mean it
it's uh you know
uh it it added greatly to the theory of
of stable matching
so you mentioned your wife jill
you mentioned stable marriage
can you tell the story of how you two
met
so we celebrated 60 years of wedded
bliss
uh last month
and and we met because uh uh i was
dating her roommate
this this was my sophomore year her
freshman year i i was dating her
roommate and
i wanted
her advice on
strategy or something like this and
anyway i
found i enjoyed her advice better than
i enjoyed a roommate
you guys were majoring the same thing no
no no because because i read something
about
working on a computer in grad school
on a difficult
computer science topic
so so she's an artist and i'm okay
and i'm a
you know geek and what was she doing
with a computer science book all right i
read the was it the manual that she was
reading what was she reading i wrote the
manual that she had had she had to take
a class in computer science okay
and and uh you're the tutor no no yeah
no we yeah we
there were tearful times uh
you know
trying to learn certain concepts but i
learned art from her
and so we we worked together
you know occasionally in design
projects but
but every year we write a christmas card
and and we each have to
compromise our
our own
notions of beauty yes
uh when did you
fall in love with her
that day that i
asked her about her her roommate
okay i mean
no i i
okay so
i i don't mind telling these things
depending on how you for how far you go
but
[Laughter]
but let me promise
let me tell you this that i
i never really enjoyed kissing
uh
until i
found how she did it
and 60 years yeah
is there a secret you can uh you can say
in terms of stable marriages of how you
stayed together so long
the topic stable marriage by the way is
not
it is
is the technical term uh yes
it's
[Music]
different people will have to
learn how to compromise and
and and
work together and and
and you're going to have ups and downs
and
and
and crises and so on um
and so as long as you don't
set your expectation on
having 24 hours of bliss
then there's a lot of hope for stability
but if you if
if you decide that it's
that that there's going to be no
frustration
[Music]
so you're going to have to compromise on
your notions of beauty when you write
christmas cards that's it
uh
you uh you mentioned that richard
feynman was someone you looked up to
yep um probably you've met him in
caltech
well we knew each other
yeah at cal tech for sure yeah
uh you are
one of the seminal personalities
of computer science he's one for physics
have you ever
is there specific things you picked up
from him
by way of inspiration or uh
so we used to go to each other's
lectures and
and uh
but but if i saw him sitting in the
front row
i would throw me for a loop actually and
i i i would i would miss a few
a few sentences
what unique story do i have about i mean
i
i i i often refer to his
his time in brazil
where he uh
essentially
said they were teaching all the physics
students the wrong way they were just
they were just learning how to pass
exams and not learning any physics
and he said
you know if you want me to prove it
you know
here i'll turn to any page of this
textbook and
i'll tell you what's wrong with this
page and and he did so and
and the textbook had been written by his
host and and it was a big embarrassing
incident but he had previously asked his
host if if he was supposed to tell the
truth
um
but but anyway it
epitomizes the way
education goes wrong uh in all kinds of
fields
uh and has to periodically
be brought
back
from from
from a process of giving credentials to
a process of giving knowledge
that's probably a story that continues
to this day in a bunch of places where
it's too easy for
educational institutions to fall into
credentialism versus uh
inspirationalism
i don't know if those are words but
sort of uh yeah understanding versus
just giving a little um
it would be plaque
and you know it's it's very much like
what we were talking about if you want
the computer to
if you want to be able to believe the
answer computer is sure it's doing that
one of the things
bob floyd showed me in the 60s there was
a
uh he loved this cartoon there was a
there were two
guys standing in front of
in those days the computer was a big
thing you know
and and the first guy says to the other
guy he said
this machine
can do in one second what it would take
uh a million people to do in a hundred
years
and the other guy says oh so how do you
know it's right
[Laughter]
that's a good line uh
is there some interesting distinction
between physics and math to you
have you looked at physics much to like
speak university feynman
so
the difference between the physics
community the physics way of thinking
the physics intuition versus
the computer science the theoretical
computer science the mathematical
sciences
do you see that as a gap are they
strongly overlapping
it's quite different
in my opinion i um i started as a
physics major and i switched into math
and
probably the reason was that i could i
could get a plus on the physics exam but
i like i never had any idea why i would
have been able to
come up with the problems that were on
those exams
but but in math
i i i knew
you know why the teacher set those
problems and i thought of other problems
that i could set too
and i believe it's quite a different
mentality
is it it has to do with your philosophy
of geek geekdom
i mean
some of my computer scientist friends
are really good at physics and others
are not and and i i'm
uh you know i'm really good at algebra
but not at geometry you
talk about different parts of
mathematics you know i just it's
so they're different kind of physical
but physicists think of things in terms
of waves
and
i can think of
things in terms of waves but it's like a
dog walking on hind legs if i'm thinking
about it so you basically you like to
see the world in in uh
in discrete ways and then this is more
continuous yeah i i i'm not sure
if turing would been a great physicist i
think it was a pretty good
chemist
i don't know but but uh but anyway i see
things
i i i believe that computer science is
largely
driven by uh a people who have
brains who work
who are good at
resonating with
certain kind of
of of concepts
and like quantum computers it takes a
different kind of brain yeah that's
interesting yeah
it's it's well quantum computers is
almost like at the intersection in terms
of brain
uh between computer science and physics
because they it involves both at least
at this at this time
but there is like the physicists i've
known
they have incredibly powerful intuition
and and there's a lot i mean statistical
mechanics so i i study
uh statistical mechanics and
you know
i mean random processes uh uh are
related to algorithms in a lot of a lot
of ways and so but there's lots of
different flavors of flavors of physics
as there are different flavors of
mathematics as well
um but but the thing is that i i don't
see
well
actually when they talk to physicists
use a completely different language than
when they're talking to
when they're writing expository papers
so i didn't understand quantum mechanics
at all from reading about it in
scientific american
but but when i read
you know how they described it to each
other talking about eigen eigenvalues
and
various mathematical
terms that
that made sense
then it made sense to me
but but hawking said that
every formula you put in a book you lose
half of your readers and so he didn't
put any formulas into the book so i
couldn't understand his book at all
you could say you understood it but
i really
i really didn't
um well feynman
also spoke in this way so feynman
i think prided himself on a really
strong intuition but at the same time he
was hiding all the the really good the
the deep computation he was doing so so
there was one thing that that uh
that i i was never able to uh yeah i
wish i had more time to to work out with
him but
i guess i could describe it for you
there's
there's something that got my name
attached to it
called knuth arrow notation but
it's a notation for very large numbers
and so uh it i find out that that
somebody invented it in in 1830s
it's fairly easy to
to understand anyway so you start with
x
plus x plus x plus x
n times
and and you can call that x n
so x n is multiplication then you take x
times x
times x times x and n time that gives
you exponentiation x to the nth power
so that's one arrow x
so x n with no arrows is multiplication
x
arrow n is x to the nth power yes just
to clarify for the
uh
so x times x times x n times is
obviously x n
and x
x plus x plus x n times
oh yeah okay and then uh xn
multiplication is x to the n uh and then
and then here the arrow is when you're
doing the same kind of repetitive
operation for the exponential so i so i
put in one arrow and i get x to the nth
power now i put in two arrows and that
makes takes x to the x to the x to the x
to the x
n times pi
so in other words if
if if it's two
uh
double arrow
uh three that would be
that would be 2 to the 2 to the 2
so that would be 2 to the fourth power
that'd be 16 okay okay so so so that's
the double arrow
and now you can
do a
triple arrow
uh of course uh and
and so on
and
and i i had this this paper called
uh
well
essentially big numbers
uh
you know you yeah you try to impress
your friend but by saying a number
they've never thought of before yeah and
and
and i i gave a special name
for it
we
designed a font for it that has script k
and so on but it but it really is 10
i think like 10
quadruple aero 3 or something like that
and i claim that that number if it
is so mind-boggling that you can't
comprehend how large it is
but anyway fine
i talked to feynman about this and he
said oh
let's just let's just use double arrow
but instead of taking integers let's
consider
complex numbers right so
you know you have
that means x to the x
x but what about x
x double arrow two
2.5 well that's not too hard to figure
out that's interpolate between those but
what what what
x double arrow
i or one plus i or some complex number
uh
and
and uh so he claimed that
that that there was no analytic
function that would
that would do that would do the job uh
but i i i i didn't know how he could
claim that that was that wasn't true
and his next question was did then have
a complex number of arrows
[Laughter]
yeah okay wow okay okay so so that's
that's fine uh that's
fine can you describe what the
[Music]
uh
new morris pratt algorithm does
and how did you come to develop it one
of the many things that you're known for
and has your name attached to it yeah
all right so
it should be actually morris pratt knuth
but we decided to use alphabetical order
when we published the paper
the problem is
uh something that everybody knows now if
they're if they're using a search engine
uh
you have a
a large collection of text
and you want to know if
if the word
canoeist appears anywhere in the text to
say or or some
some other word that's less interesting
than
but anyway that's the most interesting
thing
or something mega morris right
so we have we have
a large piece of text and it it's all
one long one-dimensional thing you know
first or second letter
et cetera et cetera et cetera and so uh
the question you would like to be able
to do this
um
and the obvious way is that let's say
we're looking for morris they don't know
that so we would we would go through and
wait till we get to letter m then we
look at the next word and sure enough
it's an o and then an r but then that oh
too bad
um
yeah the next letter is is e
so we missed we missed out on morris
and so
we go back and start looking for another
okay all over again so that's the
obvious way to do it
all right
um
and and jim morris noticed
there was a more clever way
to do it
the obvious way would have started
let's say
you know we found that let letter m at
character position one thousand
so it was started next at character
position 1001
[Music]
but
but he but he said no look we we already
read the o and the r
and we know that they aren't m's
so we could we could start
we don't have to read those over again
all right so uh
and this gets pretty tricky when
when the word isn't morris but it's more
like
abracadabra where you have patterns that
are occurring uh
like repeating patterns
at the beginning at the middle right
right so so um
he worked it out
and he put it into the system software
at berkeley i think it was where he was
he was writing some berkeley unix i
think was some routine i was supposed to
find occurrences of patterns in texas
and
and
we didn't explain it
and and so he found out that several
months later somebody had
had looked at it didn't look right and
so they ripped it out
so he had this this algorithm but it
didn't make it through
you know because he what wasn't
understood
nobody knew about this particularly
von pratt also had independently
discovered it a year or two later
i forget why
i think
vaughn was studying some
technical
problem
about palindromes or something like that
he wasn't really it juan wasn't working
on
on text searching but he was working on
on an abstract problem that
that was related well at that time steve
cook was a professor at berkeley uh
and uh
uh
it was the
greatest mistake that
berkeley cs department made was not to
give him tenure
and so steve went to
went to toronto but um but i but i knew
steve while he was at berkeley
and he had come up with a
with a very peculiar theorem
uh
about a technical concept called a stack
automaton
and a stack automaton it is a machine
that
that it can't do everything a turing
machine can do but it
it can only look at
something on
at the top of a stack or it can put more
things on the stack or or it can take
things off the stack
like it can't remember a long string of
symbols but but it can remember them in
reverse order so so if you tell a stack
of thomas on
it can tell you afterwards edcba
you know it doesn't have any other
memory except
except this one thing that it can see
and steve cook proved this amazing thing
that says
if a stack automaton can recognize a
language
where the strings of the language are
length n
in any um
amount of time whatsoever so the stack
automaton you might use a zillion steps
a regular computer can recognize that
same language in time n log n
so steve had a way of transforming
a a computation that goes on and on and
on and on
into using different data structures
into something that you can do on a
regular computer uh fast
the stack of timezone goes slow but
but but but somehow the fact that it can
do it at all
means that there has to be a fast way
so i thought this was a pretty
you know cool theorem
and so i tried it out on
on a problem
where i knew
a stack automaton could do it
but i couldn't figure out a fast way to
do it on a regular computer i thought i
was a pretty good programmer
but
but by golly
i couldn't think of any way to recognize
this language
efficiently
so i went through steve cook's
construction
i filled my blackboard
with all the
everything that stack thomas undone
did you know i i i wrote down and and
then i tried to
see patterns in that
and
and how did he convert that into a
computer program on a regular machine
um and
finally i psyched it out
what was what was the thing i was
missing so that i could
say oh yeah this is what i should do in
my program
uh
and now i have an efficient program
and and so i
uh i i would never have thought about
like
that if i hadn't had his theorem which
was purely abstract thing
actually
to try to intuit how to use the stack
automaton for the the string matching
problem yeah so so so the problem i
i had
started with was not the string matching
part but then i realized that the string
matching problem was another thing which
would also be
could be done by a stack of automatons
and and so when when i looked at what
that told me then i had a nice algorithm
for this
string matching problem uh
and and it told me
exactly what i should remember as i'm as
i'm going through the string
and i worked it out and and i wrote this
little paper called
automata theory can be useful
and and the reason was that it was first
i mean i had been reading all kinds of
papers about automated theory
but it never taught me it never improved
my programming for for everyday problems
uh it was something that you published
in journals and and and you know it was
it was interesting stuff but it but here
was a case where i couldn't figure out
how to write the program i had a theorem
from automated theory then i knew how to
write the program so this was
for me
uh
you know a change in life i started to
say maybe i should
learn more about thomas
and
and and and i i showed this note to
vaughn pratt and he said
that's
similar to something i was working on
um and then uh
and jim morris was at berkeley too at
the time
anyway he
he he's had an illustrious career but i
haven't kept
track of jim but one is my colleague at
stanford
and my student
uh later but but this was before vaughn
ron was still a graduate student and
hadn't come to stanford yet so we found
out that we'd all been working on the
same thing so so it was our algorithm we
each discovered it independently but
each of us had discovered a different
a different part of the elephant
you know a different
aspect of it and so we could put our
our
our things together it was my job to
write the paper
how did the elephants bring to life
spring to life was because i
i had drafted this paper
autonomous theory
oh it can be useful which was seen by
vaughn and then by jim and then then
then we combined
because maybe they had also
been thinking of writing something up
about it about specifically history
problem
let me ask a ridiculous question
uh last time we talked you told me what
the most beautiful algorithm is
actually
uh for strongly connected graphs
what is the hardest problem
puzzle
idea in computer science for you
personally that you had to work through
just something that was just the
hardest thing that i've ever
been involved with yeah
okay well yeah that's i don't
know how to answer questions like that
but in this case uh it's pretty clear
okay because
it's uh
called the
the birth of the giant component okay so
now let me explain that because this is
actually gets
gets into physics too
and it gets into something called bose
einstein statistics
but but
but anyway
it's got
some interesting stories and it
connected with berkeley again
so
start with the idea of a random graph
now this is
here we we just say we have n points
that are totally unconnected
and
and there's no geometry involved there's
no saying some points are further apart
than others all points are exactly
are exactly alike and
let's say we have 100 points and
and we number them from zero zero to
nine nine
all right
now let's let's take pi
uh the digits of pi so
two at a time so so we had 31 41 59 26
we we can look go go through pi
and so
so we take the first two 31
41 and let's
let's put a connection between point 31
and point 41
that's an edge in the graph so
then we take
5 9 2 6
and make another edge
and the graph gets bigger it gets more
and more
connected
as we add these things one at a time
okay so we start out with end points
and and we add uh
m edges
okay now each edge is completely
we forgot about
edges we had before we make an edge
twice we might get an edge from a point
to its selfie but
um you know maybe pi is going to
have a run of four digits in there
so we're gonna
but anyway
we're evolving a graph at random
um and
a magical thing happens
when the number of edges
is
like point four nine and
uh
so maybe n is a million
and i have
uh you know
490 000 edges
uh
then
it almost all the time
it it consists of isolated trees
not even any loops right
it's a very small number of veggies so
far
a little less than half n and right but
if i had point five one inches so a
little more than half in
so it's you know million points
510 000 edges
now it probably has
a
one component that's much bigger than
the others
um and we call that the giant component
is that can you clap so can you clarify
so
is there a name for this kind of random
super cool pie random graph
well i i call it
part the pie graph no no i
the pie graph is actually
my pie graph is based on
on binary representation of pi not the
decimal representation of pi but but but
but anyway
let's suppose i was rolling dice instead
what's that so sorry so it doesn't it
doesn't have to be pi
any source
the point is every step
choose totally at random one of those
endpoints
and choose totally at random another one
of the end points
make that an edge
that's the process yeah
so there's there's nothing magical about
pi they you're no no i was using pi to
sort of saying pi is sort of random that
nobody knows a pattern in exactly got it
i got it but it's not
yeah i i could have just as well drawn
straws or something um this was a
concept invented by erdogan rainey and
they called evolution of random graphs
and if you start out with with a large
number n
and you and you repeat this process all
of a sudden a big bang happens at one
half n there'll be two points together
then maybe we'll have half have
three uh
and then
you know
then they maybe branch out a little bit
but but they'll all be separate until we
get to one half end
and we pass one half in and all of a
sudden
there's substance to it that
there are there's a big
clump of stuff that's all joined
together so it's almost like a phase
transition of some kind it's exactly it
it's a phase transition but it's
actually it's a double phase transition
and turns out it it it happens
there's actually two things going on at
once
at this phase transition which
uh which is very remarkable about okay
so so um
a lot of the most important algorithms
are based on random processes and so i
wanted to you know i want to understand
random processes now
so there are data structures that sort
of grow this way
okay so
so dick carp one of the leading
experts on on random randomized
algorithms
had his students working looking at this
at berkeley
and we heard a rumor that the students
had
found something interesting happening
the students are
are generating this
or simulating this random evolution of
graphs and
under taking stat snapshots
every so often
take a look at what the graph is
and the rumor was that every time they
looked
that there was only one component that
had loops in it almost always they do a
million experience
and
only
three or four times did they ever ever
happen to see a loop at at this point
no more than one component with the loop
so they want you to keep till the graph
gets
completely full
uh
so it starts out totally empty and gets
more and more
more and more edges all the time uh and
and so okay
certainly a loop comes along once but
but now all the loops
stay somehow joined to that one
they're
there never were two guys with loops wow
okay in this experiment okay so anyway
this one almost always
certainly not always yeah
but but but with high very high
probability that seemed to be true so
so we heard about this rumor at stanford
and we said
if if that's true then must you know
a lot more must also be true so there's
a whole bunch there's a whole theory out
there waiting to be discovered that we
haven't ever thought about so so let's
take a look at it
and so we look closer and we find out no
it actually it's not true
but
but in fact it's almost true
namely
there's a very short interval of time
when it's true
and and if you don't happen to look at
it
during that short interval of time
then you miss it
so
that in other words there'll be a period
where they're two or three components
have loops
but
they join together pretty soon okay
so so
if you don't have
a real fast shutter speed you're going
to miss
you're going to miss that instant so
separate loops don't exist for long
that's that's it yeah you know i started
looking at this to make it quantitative
and uh
basic problem was to slow down the big
bang so that i could watch it happening
yeah i i think i can explain it actually
in fairly elementary terms deep
even without writing a formula that's
right like hawking would do uh and and
and so uh
let's let's watch the evolution and and
at first uh these edges are coming along
and they're just making
things without loops
which we call trees okay so then all of
a sudden the loop first appears so at
that point i have one component that has
a loop
all right now
now i say that the complexity of a
component
is the number of edges minus the number
of vertices
so if i have a loop i have like a loop
of length five it has five edges and
five vertices
um or or i could put a tail on that
and that would be another edge another
vertex like a zero one two complexity
kind of thing so so if the if the
complexity is zero we have one
one loop i call it a cycle or i call a
cyclic component so so cyclic component
looks like
a
a wheel
to which you attach
fibers
or trees
they go branching but there's no more
loops there's only one loop and
everything else
feeds into that loop okay and that has
complexity zero
but but a tree itself has complexity
minus one because it has
uh uh you know
like
like it might have ten vertices and nine
edges to tie the time together so nine
minus ten is minus one so
so complexity
minus one is a tree
it's gotta be connected that's what i
mean by a component it's gotta be
connected so so so if if i have ten
things connected i have to have nine
edges
can you clarify
why when complexity goes uh you can go
above zero i'm a little yes
right so
the complexity plus one is the number of
loops
so if complexity is zero i have one loop
if if if complexity is one
that means i have one more edge then i
have vertex
so i might have like
11
edges and 10 vertices
it's so it turns we call that a bicycle
because it it it's got two loops and
it's got to have two loops in it
why can't it be trees just going off of
the loop
that i would need more edges than
all right
right okay so so every time i get
another loop i i get
another excess of edges over vertices i
got you okay
so in other words uh
we start out and
after i have one loop i have one
component that has
a cycle in it not now the the next step
uh according to the rumor would be that
at the next step i would have
a bicycle
in the evolution of almost all graphs it
would go from cycle to a bicycle but in
fact there's a certain probability it
goes
from cycle to two you know
to two different cycles all right
um and i worked out the probability it
was something like five out of twenty
four
that was pretty high
it was substantial yeah
uh but still
soon they're going to merge together
almost okay so
that's so cool but but then it splits
again
after you have either either two or one
one uh the next step is you either have
three or you have two one or you have
one on one okay
and so i worked out the probability
for for those transitions
and
i worked it out up to
up to the first five transitions
and i had these so i had these strange
numbers five twenty fours and i stayed
up all night and about three a.m
i i had the numbers computed and i
looked at them and here were
the denominator was something like
20 2 3 0 2 3.
so
the probability was something over 2 3 0
2 3.
i don't know how you worked that out but
i had a formula of that you know i could
calculate the probability yeah and and i
could find the limiting probability as n
goes to infinity and and it turned out
to be this number but the denominator
was 2 0 and i and i looked at the
denominator and i said wait a minute
this number factors because
1001 is equal to 7 times 11 times 13. i
had learned that in my first computer
program so
so so
so 23023
yeah is 7 times 11 times
13 times 23.
that's not a random number there has to
be a reason
why
those small primes appear in the
denominator but my think
so all of a sudden that suggested
um
another way of looking at the problem
where small prime factors
would occur
so
what would that be so that said oh yeah
let me take the logarithm of this
formula and and sure enough it's going
to simplify
and and it happened
so
and i wouldn't have noticed it except
for this factorization
okay so i go to bed and i say okay this
is this looks like i'm slowing down the
big bang i can figure out what's going
on here
and
the next day it turned out bill gates
comes to stanford to visit uh they're
trying to sell him on donating money to
uh for a new computer science building
sure
and
and they and uh so they gave me an
appointment to talk to bill and i
and i wrote down on the blackboard this
this evolutionary diagram you're going
from one to two five twenty fourths in
all this business yeah
and i wrote it down and anyway at the
end of the day the
uh he was discussing people with the
with the uh development office and he
said boy i was really impressed with
what professor knuth said
about this
giant component
and uh and so uh you know i i love this
story because it shows that
theoretical computer science has is
really worthwhile you know
does bill have you ever talked to bill
gates about it uh since then
yeah
that's a cool yeah that's a cool little
moment in history yeah but but anyway
he happened to visit on exactly the day
after i had
i i had found this pattern and
that allowed me to to crack the problem
so you know so that i could develop the
uh the theory some more and understand
what's happening in the big but
uh
because i could i could now write down
explicit formulas for stuff right and so
it would you know
it would work not only the first few
steps but also they'll study the whole
process and and i worked further and
further and i
with two authors co-authors and we
finally figured out
that the probability
that
the rumor
was true in other words look at the
evolution of a of a random graph going
from zero zero to to complete
and say what's the probability that at
every point in time there was only one
component with a cycle
we started with this rumor saying
there's only one site there's only one
component with the cycle and and
uh
so
it's a hundred percent
the rumor was that was 100
it turned out the actual numbers was
like
percent or i i don't know i should
remember the number but i do but i don't
have it with me but but anyway
but but the but the number
it it turned out to be like 12 over pi
squared or
anything
it was a nice
it related to pi yeah um and we could
never have
done that with
but so that's the hardest problem i ever
saw in my life was to prove that this
probability is is it was proven
the probability was proven yeah i was
able to prove this that this
and and and this should shed light on a
whole bunch of other things about random
graphs that that was sort of the
the major
thing we were asked after that's super
cool
what was the connection to physics that
you mentioned
well bose einstein statistics is the
study of how
molecules uh
bond together
without geometry
without distance
you created the tech type setting system
and released it as open source
just on that little aspect
why did you release it as open source
what is your vision for open source
no okay well that the word open source
didn't exist at that time but we but i i
didn't want proprietary rights over it
because i saw
how
proprietary rights were holding things
back
in the late 50s
people at ibm developed the language
called fortran they could have
kept it proprietary they could have said
only ibm can use this language everybody
else has to but but they didn't
they said anybody who can write who can
translate fortran
into the
into the language of their machines uh
is allowed to
make fortran compilers too
um
on the other hand in the typography
industry i had
seen a lot of languages that were
developed for
composing pages
and each manufacturer had his own
language for composing pages
and that was holding everything back
because people
were tied to a particular manufacturer
and and then a new equipment is invented
a year later but printing printing
machines they have to
expect to amortize the cost over 20 30
years
so you didn't want that for tech
i didn't need the income
okay i already i i already had
uh
a good job
and
you know
my books were
people were buying enough books that i
that
that it would bring me
plenty of supplemental income for
everything my kids needed for education
whatever
so there was no reason for me to try to
maximize income any further
income is sort of a threshold function
if you don't have
if you don't have enough you're starving
but if if you get over the threshold
then you start thinking about
philanthropy or else or you're trying to
take it with you but uh
but anyway there's a i had
my income was over the threshold so
so that i i didn't need
to keep it and so i specifically could
see the advantage of
of of making it open for everybody
do you think uh most software should be
open
so i think that
people should charge for non-trivial
software but not for trivial software
yeah you give an example of i think
adobe photoshop versus [ __ ] on linux
as photoshop has value which so
it's definitely worth paying
paying for all the stuff i mean
and i mean
well they keep adding
adding stuff that just
that my wife and i don't
care about but
somebody does but i mean but they have
built in a
fantastic uh uh undo feature for example
in photoshop
where you you you can go through a
sequence of a thousand complicated steps
on graphics and
it can
take you back anywhere in that sequence
yeah
with really beautiful algorithms i mean
yeah it's it's oh that's interesting i
didn't think about what algorithm it
must be some kind of efficient
representation really yeah i know i mean
there's a lot of really subtle
nobel prize class like
creation of intellectual property in in
there
and uh
and
with patents uh you've got a limited
time to
uh i mean eventually the idea of patents
is that you publish
so that it's not secret it's not a trade
secret
that said
you you've said that i currently use
ubuntu linux on a standalone laptop
it has no internet connection
i occasionally carry flash memory drives
between the machine and the macs that i
use for network surfing and graphics
but i trust my family jewels only to
linux
why do you love linux
the version of linux that i use is
stable i i i
actually i i'm gonna have to upgrade one
of these days but
to a newer version of ubuntu yeah i'll
stick with ubuntu but
but uh right now i'm running
something that doesn't support a lot of
the new
software
the last stability i don't remember the
number
like 14 anyway it's it's quite
and i'm going to get a new computer um
i'm getting new um solid-state memory
instead of
kind of a hard disk and the basics
well let me ask you
um
sticking on the topic of tech
um
when thinking about beautiful typography
what is your favorite letter number or
symbol
i know i know ridiculous question but is
there some
let me show you there
or
look at the last page
at the very end of the index
what is that
there's a book by dr seuss called on
beyond zebra and he gave a name to that
did you say dr seuss gave a name to that
dr seuss this is uh s-e-u-s-s he he
wrote children's books
in the 50s
40s and 50s
wait are you talking about cat in the
hat doctor
yeah
that's it yeah i like how you hit this
on on beyond zebra did he did did it get
to
soviet union
[Laughter]
yeah doctors no we did
dr seuss did not come to the soviet
union but
since you oh actually i think he did
actually a little bit when we were
um
that that was a uh
his maybe cat in the hat or or green
eggs and ham i think was used to learn
english oh okay so i think it made it
that way my my
okay i i didn't like those as much
as bartholomew cubbins but but i used to
know
bartholomew covens by heart when i was
young
so what the heck is this symbol we're
looking at
there's so much going on he has a name
for it at the end of his book on beyond
zebra
who made it he did he did
so there's
it looks like a bunch of vines
uh well is that symbol of existence
by the way he
he made a movie in the early 50s
um i don't remember the name of the
movie now you can probably find it on
easily enough but
it it features uh
dozens and dozens of pianos all playing
together at the same time and
but but the all the scenery is sort of
based on the kind of artwork that was in
his books and uh
the fantasy big
you know
based of zeus land or so
and i saw the movie only once or twice
but it's
but it's quite
i'd like to see it again
that's that's really fascinating that
you gave him
they gave him shout out here
okay
is there some elegant basic symbol that
you're attracted to some
uh
give something that gives you pleasure
something used a lot
pi
pi of course
uh i try to use pi
i as often as i can when i need a random
example
[Music]
because it doesn't have any
known characters so for
so for instance
i i don't have it here to show you but
do you do you know the put the uh the
the game called masu m-a-s-y-u
no it's it
it's a great
recreation i mean
sudoku is easier to understand but
matthew is it it is more addictive uh uh
you you have black and white stones like
like on a go board
and you have to draw a path that
goes straight through a white stone and
makes a right angle turn at the black
stone
um and
it turns out to be really
really nice puzzle because it
doesn't involve numbers but with this
visual but it's
3d pleasant to to play with
so so i wanted to
use it as example in art of computer
programming and i have
i have exercise on how to design cool
massive puzzles
and uh you can find that on wikipedia
certainly uh
as an example
m-a-s-y-u
um and and so i and so i decided i would
take pi
the actual
image of it and it
had pixels and i i would put a stone
wherever
it belongs in the letter pi in the greek
letter pi
and and but
the problem was
find a way to make some of the stones
white some of the stones black so that
there's a unique solution to the
mossview puzzle
that was
a good test case for my algorithm on how
to design master puzzles because i i
insisted in advance
that the stones had to be placed in
exactly the positions that make the
letter pie make a juice letter okay
all right that's cool and and
i saw you know
and it turned out there was a a
a unique way to do that
um and so
so pi is a
source of
of examples where i can
where i can prove that i'm starting with
something that isn't canned
and most most recently i was
writing about something called graceful
graphs
uh graceful graphs
is the following
you have a graph that has
m edges to it
all right and
you attach numbers to every vertex
in the following way so every time you
have an edge between vertices
you take the difference between those
numbers
and and that difference is it's got to
be
tell you what edge it is so so
one edge two numbers will be one apart
there'll be another edge where the
numbers are two apart and so uh great
computer problem can you find a graceful
way to label a graph
so i started with a so i started with a
graph that i use for
an organic graph not
not a
mathematically symmetric graph or
anything and i take this i take the 49
states of the united states
uh
the edges that go from one state to the
next state so for example california be
next to oregon
nevada
arizona okay
and and
and i include this district of columbia
uh so i have 49 i can't get at la alaska
and hawaii in there because they don't
touch you have to be able to drive from
one to the other so is there a graceful
labeling of of the united states
each state gets a number
and then if california is number 30 and
oregon is number 11.
that edge is going to be number
19. the difference between those right
okay
so is there a way to do this for for all
the states
and at that and so i was i was thinking
of having a contest uh
for people to to get it as graceful as
they could
uh but my friend tamara kiki
actually solved the problem by proving
that i mean i was able i was able to get
it down
within seven or something like that he
was able to get a perfect solution
the actual solution or to prove that a
solution exists
more precisely i i had figured out a way
to put labels on so that
all the all the uh all the edges were
labeled somewhere between one and 117
but but there were some some get some
gaps in there because
i should really have gone from one to
105 or what the whatever the number is
so
i gave myself too much
you know a lot of slack
he did it without any slack whatsoever a
perfect grace for labeling
and and so i you know i
call out the contest uh because the
problem is already solid and too easy in
a sense because tom was able to do it in
an afternoon
um he sorry he did the algorithm or for
this particular uh for the stick united
states for the united states this
problem is
this problem is incredibly hard i mean
for the general generally okay
but it's like it's like coloring but it
was very lucky that we worked for the
united states sure um i think but but i
mean the theory is still very uncomplete
but but but anyway then tom came back a
couple days later and he had been able
to not only find a graceful labeling but
he
but
the label of washington was 31.
the label of
of idaho
was 41 following the digits of pi
yeah
going across
the topic of the united states he has
the digits of pipeline did he do it on
purpose
he was able to still get a graceful
labeling with that with
it's a miracle okay but yeah but um i
i i
i like to use pie in my book you see and
this is
all roads lead to pie yeah somehow um
somehow often hidden
uh in the middle of like the the most
difficult problems
can i ask you about uh
productivity
productivity yeah you said that quote my
scheduling principle
is to do the thing i hate most
uh on my to-do list
by week's end i'm very happy
can you explain this process to a
productive life
oh i see well
but all the time i'm working out and
what i want i what i don't want to do
but still i'm glad to have all those
unpleasant tasks finished yes is that
something you would advise to others
well i yeah i i i don't know how to say
it
during the pandemic i feel my
productivity actually went down by half
um
because i have to
um
i have to communicate by
writing which is slow i have to
i mean i i don't like to send out a bad
sentence so i
you know i go through and reread what
i've written and edit and fix it so so
everything takes a long a lot longer
when i'm
when i'm communicating by
by text messages um
instead of just
you know
together with somebody in the room and
it's also
slower because the libraries are closed
and stuff
but there's another thing about
scheduling that i learned from my mother
that i should probably tell you and that
is
um it's different from what people in
robotics field do which is called
planning
so she had this principle
that was
see something that needs to be done and
do it
you know i would just
instead of saying i'm going to do this
first and do this first
just
you know
just do it oh yeah pick this up you know
but you're at any one moment there's a
set of tasks that you can do and you're
saying a good heuristic
is to do the the one you want to do
least
right
the one i haven't got any good reason
i think
that i'll never be
able to do it any better than i am now
i mean there are some things that that i
know
if i do
something else first i'll be able to do
that one better yeah but but but there's
some that are going to be harder because
you know
i i i i've forgotten some of the
groundwork that went into it or
something like that
so so i just finished uh a pretty tough
part of the book and
uh
and so and so now i'm
you know doing the parts that are more
fun
but but but the the other thing is as
i'm writing the book of course i want
the reader to think that i'm happy all
the time i'm writing the book i i'm you
know that it's upbeat i i i can have
humor i can you know i can i can say
this is cool you know
wow
this uh i have to i have to disguise the
fact that
it was painful in any way to come up the
road to that excitement is painful yeah
it's laden with pain
okay is is there um you've given some
advice to people before
but can you um
can you you give me too too much credit
but anyway this is my this is my turn to
just not to say things that that that i
believe but
but i want to preface it by saying um
i also believe that
other people do a lot of these things
much better than i do so i can only tell
you
my side of it
so
can i ask you to give advice
to young people today to high school
students to college students whether
they're geeks
or
the other kind
about how to live a life that they can
be proud of how to have a successful
career how to have a successful life
it's always the same as i've said before
i guess
not to
do something because you
because it's trendy
but
but it's something that you personally
feel that you were called to do
right rather than somebody else expects
you to do
how do you know
you're called to do something
you try it and it works or you or it
took or it doesn't work i mean you you
learn about yourself
life is a binary search you try
something and you find out oh yeah i
have a background that helped me with
this
or
or or
maybe
maybe i
i could do this if i worked a little bit
harder but you try something else and
you say wait i have really no intuition
for this and it looks like
uh
you know it looks like it doesn't have
my name on it
it was there advice along the way that
you got
about what you should and shouldn't work
on or do you just try to listen to
yourself yeah
i probably overreacted another way
when something when i see everybody else
do going some way i probably
i i'd probably say not too much
competition
but yeah but but uh
but mostly i i
played with things that were interesting
to me and then later on i found
oh actually the most important thing i
learned was how to be interested in
almost anything yeah i mean not to be
bored
it hurts it makes me
very sad when i when i see kids talking
to each other and they say
that was boring
and
to me
a person should feel
upset if he would help
if he had to admit that he wasn't able
to find something interesting
so uh uh
you know the skill they
they say i haven't learned how to
how to enjoy life i have to have
somebody entertain me instead of right
that's really interesting it is a skill
uh david foster wallace
i really like
the thing he says about this which is
the key to life is to be unborable
and i do really like you saying that
it's a skill
because i think that's a really good
that's really good advice which is if
you find something boring
that's not
i don't believe it's because
it's boring it's because you haven't
developed i have learned how to how to
find the beauty and how to find the fun
in it
yeah that's a that's a really really
good point
you know sometimes it's
more difficult than others
to do this but
i mean during the covet
lots of days when i did when i never saw
another human being but um
but
i i i still find other ways to
it still was a pretty fun time yeah yeah
i came earlier i came a few minutes
early
today and i
walked around foster city
i didn't want you know i didn't know
what was going on in foster city i saw a
beautiful
some beautiful flowers at the nursery at
home depot a few blocks away
life is amazing it's full of amazing
things like this yeah i just sometimes
i'll i'll sit there and just stare at a
tree
nature is beautiful
uh let me ask you the big ridiculous
question i don't think i asked you last
time i have to ask this time in case you
have a good answer
what is the meaning of life
our existence here on earth
the whole thing
[Laughter]
no no you can't you can't i will not
allow you to uh to try to escape
answering this question you have to
answer definitively
uh because they're they're surely
surely don knuth there must be an answer
what is the answer is it 42 or wherever
yeah well i don't think it's the
numerical that's that's
okay but all right so so anyway um
it's only for me and
but i
but i personally
think of my belief that
that god exists although i have no idea
what that means
but i believe that there is
some
something
beyond human
uh
capabilities
um and it might be uh
uh it might be some ai
but but whatever it is but but whatever
i but i do believe that
that there is
something
that goes beyond
the realm of human understanding
but but that that i can
try to
learn more about
how to resonate with whatever that
being would like me to do
so do you think you can
have occasional glimpses of that being i
i strive for that
not that i
ever think i'm going to get close to it
but but it's not
it's not for me it's it's saying what
should i do
that that big being wants me to do
that's that's you know i i'm trying to
ask
what that
i mean does that being want me to to be
talking to lex friedman right now you
know and i said yes okay but thank you
well thank you
but
yeah what i'm trying to say is
i'm not trying to say what
of all the
strategies i could choose or something
which one
i i try to do it not not strategically
but i try to
to
imagine
that i'm following somebody's wishes
even though
you're not smart enough to to know what
they are yeah
but that funny little dance well i i i
mean this ai or whatever is it probably
is
it is smart enough to help to give me
clues
and uh
to make the whole journey from clue to
clue
a fun one yeah i mean it's as so many
people have said it's the journey not
the destination
and
people live
live through crises help each other all
these things come up
history repeats itself
you try to say in the world today
is there any government that's working i
i read history i i know that things were
they they were they were
there were a lot worse
in many ways there's a lot of bad things
all the time
and i read about
you know i i look at
things and people had good ideas and
they were working
on great projects and then i know that
it didn't succeed though in the end
uh but but the new insight i've gotten
him actually
in that way was i i was reading
uh what what book was i reading now
recently it was
it was by ken follett and it was called
the man from saint petersburg but it but
but it was talking about the prequel to
world war one
and winston churchill
according to this book uh sees that
that germany has been spending all its
gold reserves uh building up a huge
military
and there's no question that
if germany would attack england that
england would be wiped out
um
so he wants russia to help
uh
to attack germany from the other side
because germany doesn't have enough of
an army to
to be fighting two wars at one
okay now
then there's an anarchist in russia
who sees
that
wars are
something that leaders start but
actually people get killed
and so he
wants to stop
any alliance between england and russia
because that would mean that
a thousand thousand people of russia
would would be killed that wouldn't be
otherwise killed
all right and so
his his life's goal
is to assassinate
a russian prince who's visiting england
because that will make will mean the
czar will not form the alliance all
right
so we have this
question
about what should the government do
should it actually
do something that will lead to
you know is is the war inevitable or is
there a way to have peace and and this
just did and it struck me that if i were
in a position of responsibility work for
people's lives
in most cases i wouldn't have i wouldn't
have any confidence that any of my
decisions were good
that that that these these questions are
too
hard
probably for any human being but
certainly for me
well i think
i think coupling the
not being sure
that the decisions are right so that
that's actually a really good thing
coupled with the fact that you do have
to make a decision
and carry the burden of that and
ultimately i have faith in human beings
and the great leaders to arise
uh and help build a better world i mean
that's the hope of democracy that's done
yeah
enhance their abilities with uh
with algorithms
[Laughter]
uh well put done
it's such a huge honor i've you've been
an inspiration to me and to millions for
such a long time um thank you
for spending your really valuable time
with me once again
it's a huge honor i really enjoyed this
conversation
thanks for listening to this
conversation with donald knuth to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you with some words
from don knuth himself
science is what we understand well
enough to explain to a computer art is
everything else we do
thank you for listening i hope to see
you next time
you